do we have wheel of punishment filled
out there Seaton we got everything that
we need we do yeah we've got everything
on there okay give the audience a
sampling it's gonna have to wear a Zeke
style belly shirt which should be pretty
interesting joining us in studio with
his picks he lost the bet Michigan
Michigan State and at stake was a wheel
of punishment between seat and Paulie
and Shea and so Shea being a die-hard
Cowboy fan what else do you have on the
wheel of punishment after during the
segment after Andrew says anything he's
gonna have to say great point pearl oh
man I love how the Cowboys are airing it
out with dak Prescott yeah so then
that's when he would say great point
pearl pearl hi so JJ is just finding out
what's on the wheel of punishment what
else do you have on there he's has to
wear an Oklahoma Jersey that's part of
the wheel of punishment you gotta wear
Oklahoma seen these things about Jason
Gary 60 seconds where you see something
that's a lot of time ginger yes it is
gotta say prepare your speech for next
week nice things about Eli Manning know
can you say something nice about sling
blade besides pity I mean what are you
gonna give him all right what else do
you have there so you gotta sing hail to
the Redskins oh I do like that one
take the vices off and give me hail to
the Redskins for both of those no what's
wrong with that because I this is a punt
wheel of punishment
that's punishing my body Danny you do
that on your own your help not a drop
alcohol in here again no I know by the
way here's the you went foreign to the
only real mistake you had was letting
Paulie take advantage of you again four
and two
during the this past week so you're 15
and 15 and one on the year but you lost
the wheel of punishment Beth and you
countin the the bets that I lost to him
to Paul
yeah in my win loss thing well Lenny
right well we can put those aside if you
want it should be a separate category as
a sickness and then you've won the
over/under
you want $100 with that with Washington
over/under
what's our tally now where we at
financially Paulie
think we're you owe us a hundred I think
we're up three hundred one point we're
down to where you owe us a hundred and
then we have a five-star special this
week if you went oh here we go here we
go all right so you make your picks and
then Paulie has a five-star special if
you want to engage with that for a hundy
or something else that that's it let's
see I think it's only fair to throw on
another wheel of punishment
double or nothing one one like you do
this one and then somebody does the next
one okay jerks all right let's see so
Jake give me your picks for this week
cow plus 16
Georgia Tech plus six and a half
Northern Illinois minus six and a half
Maryland plus three in Texas right now
is plus eight and a half of it hits nine
I'm banging it Danny okay Paulie your
five star special for Shane Irving well
I'm gonna testify here's what we were
going to offer Shea mm-hmm we were gonna
take Indiana getting four in the first
half against Michigan at home we were
gonna take in the end of the cover then
I go nowhere near campus anymore no he
got burned by hardball several times now
Dan the Naval Academy five yeah
try this on for size big boy Navy at
Memphis Memphis is going three given
three and a half hold it we're taking
Navy outright outright winner money on
moneyline Navy outright winner Navy
shocks Memphis Navy's ranked men where's
the game while Memphis beat UCLA at home
recently Memphis at Memphis night game
Memphis four and one and Memphis is
given three and a half you over/under 71
damn it
Navy five and OH so this is straight up
Memphis against Navy Navy on the road
what's this for this is gonna be for
another wheel of punishment God or cash
what kind of cash
oh yeah if you want to do money you can
but that's kind of boring didn't go
ahead what about money how much I think
we need it we probably we need it with
Danny no it's a wheel I made the
decision it's another wheel all right
are you into Memphis straight up beating
the Naval Academy
don't take the men damn it to hell
don't do me dirty dating come on
Nautica let's see it Danny alright come
on come on seventeen oh come on
seventeen yes it is yes it is next week
come on you have this and that was on a
small sliver - what was it next - what
was in it what was it next to there
Seaton looks like Zeek belly all right
maybe you got off easy here next week at
this time you have to like I learn that
song yes you have to learn the hail to
the Redskins son and I have to sing it
yes and we have the wheel of punishment
bet with the front row and you have
Memphis straight up against the Naval
Academy come on for another wheel of fun
now do I get to make the slivers if if
the dentist if the front row lose when
they lose Annie yes yes I get to make oh
this is gonna be good yeah yeah you're
gonna play like an IV of was gonna be
bad y'all might get divorced after this
che nervous the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience